This listening to radio
lab radio from W. N y.
S? Yup. N. N. P. R.
Okay. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
We are super, super excited to
talk with you. Oh, same in me.
I'm sorry about the delay and so,
oh, that's fine. No, it's a busy day.
Life is crazy. Life is crazy. I know.
But uh, you were so enthusiastic,
so I just, I need to talk to
these guys. They really mean it.
This is Alex Alexandre Gumbo, Gumbo,
Ma. Are you Norwegian all the way back?
Yeah. Typical Norwegian, you know,
if typical includes things like biking
Sahara and climbing Everest and things
like that.
He's kind of a professional adventurer
and we got him into the studio because he
made a video last year on one of
his trips. Get tell you this video.
It's maybe the most amazing
Internet video I've ever seen.
I think so too. So let me just
set the scene for you. Okay.
What you see in the video is this
Guy Alex kind of moving along this,
he's on skis, this snowy snow scape
[inaudible] he's filming himself.
He's got the camera in his right hand.
Where is he exactly? Antarctica. Oh,
he's on a three month track to the
South Pole and back by himself.
And what he'd been doing is every
couple of days on his trip, you know,
everybody 200 kilometers. And so he
would bury stuff in the snow, some,
some fuel and uh, and sometimes a
little bit of gear that I didn't use.
Was that just to lighten
your load? Yeah. You know,
cause every ounce of unneeded
weight has to go. So in this video,
it's date 86, almost
three months since I left.
That's three months of walking 10
hours a day and I lost almost 25 kilos.
55 pounds. He's exhausted.
Oh,
he's come upon his last cash.
So on the last cash where
this video is captured,
what you see is Alex Neil
and the snow start to dig.
[inaudible] I'm telling
you that I'm quite hungry.
Whatever's in this last cash in the snow,
it's been three months since he buried it.
So I didn't really recall what was there.
[inaudible] he helps it sound good. Cool.
So he digs up this bag of stuff, starts
rifling through it. There's ticket and
[inaudible] gasoline, some zinc
ointment. It's just a mess.
Nothing. It's pretty much all press down.
Excuse me. That awesome bro.
But then Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible]
he holds up good.
[inaudible] devil back
of cheese doodles. Yeah.
[inaudible]
then he throws it up in the air. Yeah.
and then this is, this
is my favorite part.
He just freezes and he's staring
off into the distance. Almost like,
did that happen? [inaudible] killer.
Is it real?
Okay,
so he starts to dig some more and then
bye.
[inaudible].
What's it? This huge chocolate bar.
It's milk chocolate and then it's
just like he finds the Mentos
I find more and more and
Lauren Woo.
Have you ever been that happy in your
life? Well, I've been thinking about that.
How? When did you shout
last time you were so happy.
I think that's why we've been watching
this video over and over again because
none of us can remember.
It's like what stands between you and
that feeling is a really interesting
question. Yeah. It's a
free mounts with hunger.
Actually,
I think the reason I liked this video
so much is not just because he's happy.
He said he somehow stumbled
into this moment of perfection.
It's just like a perfect situation by
being so tired and so hungry and finding
such a stash of candy that
he had forgotten to, he left.
He created a moment of just
absolute complete bliss.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] in this hour on radio lab,
we're going to be searching for
moments like Alex had up in Antarctica.
We're going to be searching for
bliss, bliss of all different sorts,
perfect moments,
perfect worlds kind of blistered slips
right through your fingers and the kind
of bliss that just might last. And last,
right? We're going to begin with a story
that, uh, kind of inspired this show.
We would have never done a show
about the word bliss, where it,
not for the following story,
which is about a bliss. A,
what do you mean a better? That'll
make sense in just a second.
A story comes from our producer Tim
Howard, and it begins with a box of tapes.
Uh, alright. So check it
out. This is in my office.
And you've got a rectangular
package here. What is,
what is a very old looking box?
It doesn't look like much. It's
just about like 15 cassettes.
Tape number six, singing and
playing to friends in America.
[inaudible]
okay, so this is Charles, Charles Casey.
You'll bliss in both an amazing
character. And that's Richard.
Richard [inaudible]. He's a
fellow who gave me the cassettes.
He was a friend of Charles. Yeah.
So these were just like sitting
in his attic or something, garage.
He looked like, I suppose a little
known him, a little Leprechaun, almost
[inaudible] he was short, bald
and laughter the whole time.
[inaudible] it's a lovable character.
Simple as that. This is my favorite one.
Gay Nicholas. Yet we just like, just
explain why we're talking about this guy.
Sure.
Because these tapes tell an amazing
story about a guy who really embodied
his name and he tried to save the world,
but ultimately just tried too hard.
Fall into that void in
my life. K in grade eight
we can start the story here. This is from
a lecture that he gave decades later.
So the story goes,
it's 1908 and he's a little kid living
in what's now the Ukraine. Okay.
And His name is Carl Blitz, not
Charles list, not Charles Bliss,
Carl Blitz, B. L. I. T. Z.
That's his original name and a little
Carl was fascinated by tales of
discovering adventure.
My name is Erika Okrent.
Erica wrote about Charles Bliss and
there's a great book called in the land of
invented languages. Getting back
to the story one day, she says,
when Carl was 11 a lecture
came through town about some
Austin polar expedition,
polar expedition,
two explorers talking about their trek
across the North Pole and he was so
inspired by what he saw and heard at
that lecture did. Even decades later,
he couldn't talk about it
and my father took me
through this. I shoot me
without getting choked up.
[inaudible] my father took
me to this lecture and fed.
I show Nay who left? One Rose,
just Jessica CUNY sisters.
And when all people got into the ice
and snow in on almost chipping this bull
walk for a walk. We're in
search of knowledge for a idea
as he tells it on those tapes.
That was the beginning of his big idea
that was going to change the world.
Fast forward a few years,
they came to Ghana after the first girl
who did end up going to the Technical
University of Vienna.
I was suddenly discovered to be the
best mandolin player in Australia.
And one time I played with a full opera
orchestra under the action as a composer
Francesca. Uh, so those were the days
and then everything changed. In 1938
[inaudible] across the Austrian border,
the Nazis came to town,
Nazis came to town,
he was sent to Depauw and
then Buchenwald you know,
the concentration camps,
feelings won't be shown
desire to end my life
all around him. People were being worked
to death or outright exterminated,
but his wife Claire was a
German Catholic with connections
and clear am I good vibes, sluggish,
my mandoline and my guitar
into the concentration game.
[inaudible]
I became so famous amongst
notches. For instance,
I blocked fear would come into
[inaudible]. I can say bitch
[inaudible]
and you could say that it was here in
book and wall that Carl started to develop
his ideas about language, about the
ways that you can manipulate words.
For instance, there was this one song
that all the prisoners saying, Yep,
well who fleet one of the
[inaudible] songs? I can ever mean
the saddest lyrics in the
world. At a certain point,
Carl started to play around
with this song. You know,
he'd swap out some of the
sad lyrics for some jokes,
sing it for his fellow prisoners,
and then laughed and laughed and laughed
and for God for a few minutes that the
orange of darkest and the
most terrible [inaudible].
And on the flip side,
every evening the guards would
march all the prisoners outside,
force them to stand there in the
cold, in front of these loudspeakers,
make them listen to these speeches.
Wow.
Speeches of Hitler and
Gerbils screaming Nazi slogan.
Yes.
Which means Germany above all
did I say I got to start with
the rice bags [inaudible] words,
which [inaudible] which does you mean? But
after about a year,
his wife somehow wrangled a a
British visa for him and he gets out,
thank heavens those dreadful times are
gone and now I can play here for you and
improvisation as it
comes into my mind. Yeah.
[inaudible]
in 1939 he went to Britain,
then got a job as a
manager of [inaudible],
but he arrived in England just as
[inaudible].
The blitz begins, the German start
to bomb every major city in England.
The noise did you hear at the moment
is the sound of air raid siren
and every time he'd introduce
himself to somebody new they shutter,
that can't be your name. Yeah.
Because of like blitzkrieg good
to have that associate. Yes.
God going off,
he had a good business was named like
blitz and so I changed from the war,
like rich to the peace for base.
That was how he became Charles Bliss.
Bliss has all the right associations.
So he went forward with the feeling of
that he was now bliss and would bring
happiness to the world. And a year later,
he and his wife ended up in China and
Shanghai where there was a big population
of Xcel, Jews. Shanghai was the only
place that would take them at that
time. And they're in
China. And then in China,
I got Joe Opportunity of my lifetime
and now we come to his big idea.
I realize what I did not know that
the Chinese have a different way of,
right. He became enraptured by
the Chinese writing that he saw
the Chinese use symbols
and each symbol is a word.
And he writes about having this epiphany
when he started the Chinese symbol for
man,
he saw that the Chinese written form
of man sort of looks like a man.
It looks like a stick figure
man. And it means man,
he doesn't even know what
the Chinese word for man is.
He doesn't know how to say
man, but that doesn't matter.
He is skipping the word and
going directly into the meaning.
So here was a way of
getting beyond language.
You could think of the word in any
language if you see it in the symbol
was a revelation. Why? Well,
Gotcha.
I mean,
think back to the concentration camps
when they were outside in front of those
loudspeakers listening to
Hitler's saying stuff like,
no. [inaudible]
Paralis you know, Germany above
all that phrase [inaudible]
Charles knew that it
actually predated the Nazi.
That was cool a hundred
years earlier in 1848
and originally it was meant as a rallying
cry to bring together all of these
separate principalities.
You see the robot where you
can't go book structure, you can
that spoke German, but
these were not one country.
So when they said Deutschland
Alice, it meant university
unified Germany,
the nation above the states. Oh, suit
wasn't necessarily an aggressive thing.
Yeah,
no, but Hitler turn this around.
Hitler changes the meaning instead
of the nation above all states.
He changed it to the nation.
Never seen. You've got all the
conditional, the word bubble,
all other nations. So
you'd see what happened.
This phrase that started meaning
one thing, unification. Yeah,
became the opposite. Yeah.
This is what the Nazis did.
Yours works nice.
It would bend words to obscure
the truth of what they were doing.
Extermination did call it solution.
By doing that. As he saw it,
they were able to convince
good, sane people,
his neighbors to go along
with the genocide. [inaudible]
and I realized that [inaudible] must
be done to make language more to it.
The nature words were the problem.
Words made people do cruel things to
each other. They bear our society apart.
Words were dangerous instruments.
They caused violence. They cause wars.
So when he saw the Chinese symbol for
man, he thought this might be the answer.
And that idea came up to me that I would
should invent shimmers like the Chinese
symbols, but even clearer,
he just show simple and pictorial
that even children can read them.
If he could sit down and work it out.
You look at the symbol and
know what it meant instantly,
regardless of what language you spoke,
you wouldn't even need words which
he felt could be manipulated.
You could just have the symbol and get
straight to the truth of the manner and
the way he saw it. Right off the bat,
you'd have all of these benefits.
Freshmen didn't finish English when an
Estonian language barriers would be out
the window.
Everything from traffic accidents
to health problems could be avoided.
He thought if his symbol
system would just be adopted.
He had this vision that
high level political and
commercial negotiations would
be done in symbols.
Did he say anything as grand as like or
wouldn't happen constantly and even of
course
he reckon Hitler wouldn't have happened
basically that if the German people had
understood the symbols, they wouldn't
have copped gerbils propaganda.
That's a pretty tall order, but
it did seem to be what he thought.
Everything could be cured by the system.
He's the biggest dreamer ever. Yeah.
How did he go about doing this?
He started working out with the
basic lines and shapes would be,
he also wanted to make sure you
could produce it with a typewriter,
so it had to be a limited set of
shapes out of which everything could be
created.
Okay, so he works on it for
seven years, seven years,
and he comes up with that.
Wow. That is a big way.
This massive book called list symbolics,
Symantec ology illogical
writing for an illogical world.
It says it all where he explains the
logic of his system. For example here,
here's a symbol for sword, which
looks exactly like a sword.
And then the sword plus a forward
Arrow means attack. I buy it.
And then if you see a symbol for sword
and another symbol for sword and they're
cross, that means war.
So that's the idea that you take these
basic elemental symbols and combine them.
Exactly. All right. Here's another one.
This symbol here is like the top half
of a circle, like a little rainbow,
but just one line that means mind, mind,
it looks like the top of his skull. Ah.
Now if I were to take that symbol for
mind and I were to go like this or to put
inside it, the question
mark, that means, um,
I don't know or I have no doubt.
And, and there are also, you know,
ways to indicate verbs and adjectives
and first person, second person,
the past, the future.
But kind of the one thing that it did
that no other language or symbol system or
anything is attempted to do,
at least as far as I know,
is that it would make clear
when something was, um, well,
he called the human evaluation,
you know, basically an opinion.
And what you would do is
you'd put this a little,
this little v symbol and you put it
above this symbol and y, y v. Well,
because you know,
a v is balanced on a point and
it's unstable at wobbles to him.
That represents opinion's
human evaluations.
Anything that comes out in
the mind or take metaphors
[inaudible] the top four is he says,
you must put up the [inaudible] sign
to alert the reader. Do not take this.
Literally stop [inaudible] not
exactly bulletproof, but I can,
I can see the, the thinking there.
I actually think it's pretty impressive
and okay, so what happens next?
Well after he finishes this and he and
his wife are living in Australia at the
time, they spent all their savings on
producing this book and sent it out to
professors, government officials, heads
of state, something like 6,000 people.
And they waited for the orders
to start rolling in and um,
no response from anybody.
And then they had nothing.
[inaudible]
I can't say. I didn't
see that coming. Yeah.
And with great disappointment,
Charles went to work as a welder and yeah,
factory at General Motors.
Holden's he was working on the
production line almost as a robot.
And a year later his wife died. You
know, he had fought in world war one.
He had been in a concentration
camp. He had lived in exile,
but he says this was the
lowest point of his life
until one day, 1971 this, as he said,
this letter floated onto his desk
with this picture of this
beautiful dimpled child.
Proudly using his symbols.
Yeah,
it was a poster, a poster,
a poster. This is Shirley,
Shirley McNaughton and at the time she
was a nurse at a place called D o c c c
the Ontario crippled children's
center and named that we were very happy
to leave behind us and they've since
changed in the name.
I started there in 1968 and Shirley
was part of this group of teachers and
nurses who worked with these kids
who suffered from cerebral palsy.
If you have cerebral palsy,
it's the motor control from
the brain that's been affected,
which meant that they had trouble moving
their arms or legs and even in some
cases they couldn't speak.
They couldn't form words
and then a film that
was made of this class.
You see these young kids,
children from five to seven I'll sitting
in wheelchairs and they're watching the
teacher.
She talks to them and you
hear them try to talk to her,
but they can. These kids
had no way to communicate.
Couldn't they learn how
to [inaudible]? I read.
They could if you knew what they were
understanding and they have no way to
communicate that to you.
The only thing all these kids had were
pictures that they could point at.
They had a picture of a toilet,
picture of food, picture of a drink,
a of a bed. They were limited
to that kind of communication.
But I knew they were bright. But if they
couldn't move and they couldn't speak,
how would you know? My uh, insight on
that was the twinkle in their eyes.
But she says a lot of doctors and nurses
at the time thought I was crazy that
there really wasn't much going on
inside these kids' heads. You know,
they thought I was projecting
into the children what she needed.
She said was a way to get through to them.
And so one day she was at the library
with a colleague and they come across this
dusty old volume that had never been
checked out, called, you guessed it,
lists symbol, likes and what did you
first think when you saw it? Oh boy,
can I get back to the group?
How fast can I get back to the group
with this exactly what we need.
So do you remember what the first
symbols were? I think it was I you,
I looked kind of like a
standing person. Upright line,
small horizontal line at the base.
Yep. Next to it, the number one,
which means first person you as the
same symbol but with a number two for a
second person and then they had to have
a verb and it was long heart with an air
threat. So now they've got
a sentence. I love you.
One of our mothers,
since the happiest moment she's ever had
with her child was when her child came
home and said, I love you. You know, so
[inaudible]
surely and her staff
started to add more symbol.
They caught on and pretty soon they'd
created this giant laminated chart.
It had I and you and he, she, we and they,
then it had mother, father,
grandma, grandpa, doctor,
nurse, teacher, therapist,
postman, environment, library, dentist.
Eventually they added adjectives, happy,
sad and frustrated. All the verbs
who had loved and liked and hey,
want ni understand.
Pretty soon the kids started to do
amazing things with symbol combinations.
They started to improvise. Shirley
remembers asking one kid, Terry Martin,
what did you want to be? Refer Halloween.
Terry pointed first at the symbol for
creature, a creature, not a person.
Then he pointed at a symbol for drinks.
Then blood night creature who
drinks blood at night. Right.
You want it to be of par.
Ah, he spelled a new word.
It sounds like an explosion
with these kids. It was.
It was for the first time.
She says she could actually talk
to them like know who they were.
Yeah. You've got to know who the
leaders were in the classroom.
Those who wanted to help
others, those who copied others.
And it was around then that she and the
other teachers decided to send Charles
Bliss. That letter.
We were sharing our excitement for
this gift deed given to the children.
You know, he was in Australia,
he was an elderly man.
We had no thought that he would
come and visit us, you know,
didn't enter our mind. But
Charles Bliss, he was delighted.
[inaudible]
he had battled for so long, had
recognition and now he headed,
yeah,
mortgages, his house and it
flies over. Heavy, bad debt.
Paid my mandolin and told him jokes
and only he dances around and kisses
everybody a Fusilli than
laughter. I love that. Hello?
We had long conversations
with the kids in symbols,
right? He was very happy
about the children. Joy,
joy,
okay. But somewhere along the
way, he noticed this something
surely, surely and the
teachers had begun to
[inaudible]
augment the system.
They'd be going to add their own symbols
such as the opposite meaning symbol.
This allowed the kids to take one implicit
standard symbols and just invert the
meaning, opposite of happy, sad,
opposite of uptown, opposite of Ian,
out in to her.
This would effectively double the number
of adjectives which would be great for
the kids and we developed rules for how
to combine symbols for how to be more
precise with the symbols. She thrown
some new pronouns that we're missing.
The difference between he
and him and his. In short,
I would make the adaptations I needed
to make from the very beginning.
We were using it to meet
the children's needs,
their specific needs, and of course
that is not what he had in his mind.
He wanted a system that was universal.
Every change that she made created
like a, a separate dialect.
He would get very emotional about
it. So when he got back to Australia,
he started writing all these
letters basically taking
issue with her changes and
her failure to understand how
his system works. Meanwhile,
thanks to Shirley,
worried about blesses symbols
had spread way beyond Canada too.
France, Sweden, Israel,
Zimbabwe, Zimbabwe. Yeah.
And then Argentina, Brazil,
Finland, Iceland, Italy, Bermuda, Guam,
Japan, Portugal, Spain, Netherlands,
Hungary, Switzerland, Venezuela,
Madagascar, Yugoslavia.
It's spread to all these places. Yeah.
And in each place,
the symbols bin Inevitably get tweaked
to suit that country. For example,
in Israel because the writing
goes from right to left. Yeah.
The bliss symbols went
from right to left. Uh,
but what really pained him the most,
what really got him was that these
teachers were using his symbols as a step
toward English or French or
German or Hebrew or whatever.
It was just a way to get the
kids to their native languages.
The teachers always saw
it the way they saw it.
You start the kids on bliss and then
you introduce reading and letters and
eventually they're fully literate.
At which point you don't
need the bliss symbols.
This was the ultimate insult to him.
They were using his system to bring
these kids back to the very thing that he
was trying to get everyone
away from evil words. Yeah,
why not? Why not?
If I tried to explain it to them, they
don't want donation to me, then look,
show me what should I do? I do that.
I don't know [inaudible] and it's right
about this point in the story that you
start to hear a different Charles Place.
Shannon,
if Norton has better that it never
has been better than [inaudible].
Is he saying perverted? Yeah,
she smiles. She be guys. She she lies.
He kept sending Shirley and the other
teachers letters and the letters got
angrier. An angrier. This was
not what the language was for.
This was a universal language that had
nothing to do with spoken language.
You are ruining my system.
You are abusing it and eventually he
decided to take matters into his own hands
and he traveled back to Canada and he
started going to the various centers where
the kids were using his symbols and
seeing horrible things about me. Uh,
and getting them very upset.
That's when I got upset.
I got upset when he got them upset.
Not long after Shirley receives a
summit I have taken to court. She,
oh she, she in Dubuque.
He sued them. Yeah.
I added two more dependents.
Ms Jalen ignored on the tapes,
even suggest that he's going
to have surely put away,
put a whole knife for life. Wow.
Why was he so upset with
her in particular? Well,
because by this time she'd started
the international organization,
BCI Bliss Symbol,
communications international,
and she felt like this was a total
unique and powerful tool which could,
could and should transform lives around
the world and more teachers needed to
adopt it. Definitely.
What was he asking for?
Did he wanted us to use
the symbols in his way?
So in 1975 the BCI won a license agreement
to use the symbols in the workbooks
for the kids. But Charles
Bliss, they should all be part,
didn't give up, should all the part,
he published endless tirades and sent
them out to anybody who is listening.
Please should note and hopefully to
educate or oppose you, the patient.
What was the question was just all in all
this went on for over a decade and the
administration of the program or surely
was working was desperate to make him go
away. He had basically
destroyed the program.
And so in 1982 he and the BCI
finally come to an agreement.
Yeah.
It was a financial settlement
that satisfied him.
What was the financial
settlement? $160,000.
Wow.
You know,
we were a little program in the basement
of the Ontario cripple children's
center. We were, you
know, just a classroom.
Wow. That,
so a guy who wanted to save the world
ends up robbing a bunch of disabled kids.
I mean, that's kind of putting it crudely,
but that's how this, how it feels.
Yeah. Basically that's the, yeah.
[inaudible]
did the symbols ever go anywhere? Well,
there was a lot of excitement
about it in the beginning,
but it never spread very far.
It's used now at a few
schools in Canada and Sweden,
a couple other places. Uh,
but it never went very far because he
was constantly taking it down at every
turn.
[inaudible]
but here's what I find
most surprising. When I,
when I talked to Shirley, she didn't
have any bitterness toward him.
Not even in the worst moments when
we were having the final legal,
um, action.
We'd go through that in the morning and
as the players were packing up their
papers, Charles Bliss would reach
across the table and he'd say,
surely will you help me? And so she'd
go to lunch with him, sit with him,
and then he asked me if I would come
to his hotel that night and put the
eardrops in his ears. And
I did that every night.
He was involved with this thing.
That's just the way it was.
And it wasn't just that she takes care
of people for a living, you know, she,
she felt and still feels that Charles
Bliss had created something really new in
the world. She even told me that
when she uses blessed symbols,
she actually thinks differently.
Yes, definitely. Really, definitely.
What's different? Oh, I just think
so much more about what a word means
and it, it's, it's like
poetry in its purest form.
[inaudible]
um, well I've been playing with stained
glass down here in my retirement and you
can, you know,
you can just take the symbols and put
them into one composite and they say
things that only art
can say. It's beautiful.
They transmit a meaning
that is beyond any words.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
thanks to producer Tim
Howard and Erica Oakridge,
author of in the land of invented
languages. We'll be right back.
Bliss is having friends
and family you can rely on.
My name is Libby Graham and I am calling
from the side of the road in Dallas,
Texas awaiting rescue.
This is ginger, a socially awkward
introvert from Cabot, Arkansas.
Bliss is one day in which I do not have
to interact with another human being.
Bliss is political ignorance.
This is my moose from Malia places here,
baby sleeping in your arms.